well as nate mentioned getting students
back to the classroom is causing some
changes to ccsd's food distribution
starting today
it will no longer be happening at the
elementary school parking lot
students who are doing in-person
learning on their assigned days will
have to
have the option to receive breakfast and
lunch meals at their school location
during the school day
one family says this change is already
causing a headache
that little bit of food that they do get
during the week
five days a week and then the extra
little bags they get on the weekend
that helps a lot of us families who
struggle
month to month already with food okay so
food distribution sites will be
available for all children ages 2 to 18
years of age
monday through friday except holidays
now this will be from 7 a.m to 11 a.m
at middle school parking lots and 10 a.m
to 2 p.m
at high school parking lots coming up at
five o'clock hear what the
superintendent has to say
about the changes